Here's a good one self that's in Saint Peter's.
And I really liked this one because you can see the echoes of Jacob's vision for
the establishment of a territory there,
right?
You've got the obelisk in the middle and then you've got the directions
radiating from the center.
And of course Saint Peters,
this is St Peter's Basilica in Rome,
which is an absolutely unbelievable place.
It's just jaw dropping.
And so there's the cathedral at the back of it and then there's this circle of
pillars that surrounds it.
You can just see them a little bit on the,
on the middle left there.
That goes all the way around that entire enclosure.
And uh,
you know,
very large number of people can gather there.
And then,
so that pillar marks the center and that'd be the center of Catholicism
essentially.
That's what that represents,
right?
The,
the symbolic center of Catholicism.
Although you could make the case that the cathedral is the center,
it doesn't really matter.
They're very close together and it's,
it's half a dozen of one and six or the other.
And then here's another representation of the same idea,
right?
Is that this is why people don't like the flag to be burned,
you know,
because conservative people see the flag as the sacred thing that binds people
together.
And so they're not happy when that sacred thing is destroyed,
even if it's destroyed in the name of protest.
Whereas the people who burn flags think,
well,
there are times to dramatize the idea that the center has been corrupt and you
can demonstrate that by putting it to the torch in who has a representation
that,
that this,
that the corrupt center now has to be burned and transformed.
And the thing is they're both right.
They're both right all the time because the center is absolutely necessary and
is sacred and is almost always also corrupt and in need of reparation.
That's also an archetipal idea.
And,
and that's a useful thing to know because you know,
it's easy for young people in particular to think that,
well,
the world's going to hell in a handbasket and it's the fault of the last
generation.
They've left us this terrible mass.
And you know,
we've feeling pretty betrayed about that.
Now we have to clean it up.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
People have been thinking that for like 35,000 years.
It's not new.
And the reason it's not new,
it's cause it's always true.
You know what you're handed is a sacred center with flaws.
Always.
And it's partly because it's the creation of the dead,
right in the dead.
Can't see,
and they can't communicate.
And so they're not in touch with the present.
And so what they've bequeath to you,
apart from the fact that it might actually be corrupt,
which is a slightly different thing,
is it least blind in dead.
And so what the hell can you expect from something that's blind and dead?
You know,
you're lucky if it just doesn't stomp you out of existence.